so liebe kinder zu hause ihr fragt euch
sicher wo kommen die ganzen goldenen
vollpfosten eigentlich her
gute frage die werden tatsächlich am
nordpol vom weihnachtsmann und seinen
kleinen fleißigen elfen verpackt wir
schalten wir live hin und stellen fest
so viele essen sind da gar nicht mehr
leider nicht wir machen jetzt auch
kurzarbeit
ich habe noch genau einen kurzen 11 ja
wir sind so gut wie insolvent
ich musste jetzt sogar rudolph das
rentier verkaufen und zwar an die firma
tönnies die machen allerdings super
rentiere bürger gut so ich hab das wie
immer gehasst ich bezahl dich nicht für
slawa 12 nase also wir können jetzt
folgen vollsten turm verpackt hh wenn
einer den 2020 verdient hat dann der
legendäre schweinepriester aus
ostwestfalen unverbesserlich der clement
seit mittwoch ist nichts mehr so wie es
war ganz klar und ich kann auch eines
sagen
so werden wir nicht weitermachen
erneut kam es in einem schlachtbetrieb
der firma tönnies zu zahlreichen corona
infektion und kein mensch weiß wie viele
männer im lauf der jahre in die wurst
maschine geplumpst sind wir haben lange
überlegt welcher posten hier die
perfekte strafe wäre
und dann sind wir draufgekommen
herzlichen glückwunsch clemens zum voll
veganen vollpfosten außerdem geht ein
pfosten an ikea die idioten stellen
nämlich den gedruckten katalog ein
wahrscheinlich gut für die umwelt aber
was soll ich dann auf den scheiß noch
lesen eben man will doch alles neu
erfahren über das etagenbett gut fig
oder die klobürste viren dafür gibt es
von uns den pfosten zum selber zusammen
freak gehen dauert stunden
für wen ist der hier der geht an
weißrusslands diktator lukaschenko für
seinen wahlsieg mit über 80 prozent
für die brutale unterdrückung der
opposition und seien sehr spezielles
corona management mit wodka solltet ihr
nicht nur die hände waschen sondern ihr
solltet auch 40 bis 50 milliliter pro
tag trinken dieses virus mit spiritus
weg setzen aber nicht bei der arbeit
wieso nicht bereit das hier müssten
ungefähr 50 milliliter sein brust mein
aktueller lieblings herrscher ist ja der
thailändische könig rama reichster
monarch der welt genau rama der zehnte
meint ihn auch rama den streich zarten
lebt den größten teil des jahres gar
nicht in thailand sondern in garmisch
partenkirchen und pflegten ziemlich geil
lifestyle
hier feiert er mit seiner frau den
geburtstag seines pudels inzwischen ist
sie seine ex frau er hat sie verstoßen
sie ist im arrest
ja liebe zuschauer jetzt sind sie
schockiert aber machen sie sich keine
sorgen dem pudel geht es gut sie ist
von wegen deutschland nimmt kaum noch
asylbewerber auf steinreiche könige
dürfen jederzeit kommen für den wird
sogar mitten in lockdown ein nobel hotel
aufgemacht während in thailand
oppositionelle drangsaliert werden
der margarine monat in bayern mit
gespielin shop an mit dem outfit würde
man sogar im sommerhaus der stars
rausfliegen weiterarbeiten oder ich
verkaufe sich ein herz und guckt nicht
so böse ausbeutung entfernen ländern
bleibt legal lieferketten gesetz kommt
doch nicht
danke krukow apropos kinderarbeit was
ist eigentlich aus philipp amthor
geworden gute frage
das älteste kind der welt hatte leider
kein schönes jahr
der filip ist quasi durch falsche
freunde in seiner cdu kita gruppe auf
die schiefe bahn geraten hat blockiert
für ein windiges start up namens
augustus intelligenz was auf das
gegenteil von intelligenz hindeutet
dafür gibt es von uns diesen posten mit
amthor brille und kinder spardose kopf
hoch junge ich wette deine karriere ist
noch lange nicht vorbei und du hast doch
noch ohne ende fans wenn ich sein vater
wäre hätte ich ihn an einen wanderzirkus
verschenkt ja der typ sieht aus wie
jemand der früher auf dem schulhof der
mixed wurde am tor muss ich mal richtig
einkaufen und eine alte ballack ja da
die sicht gar nichts wunderbar so und
jetzt vor packst du den job kosten und
legt noch die jurybegründung dazu toll
und was machst du so lange du fauler
sack ich habe jetzt zoom konferenz mit
allen kindern des planeten so jetzt
passt mal auf ihre kleinen brazen dieses
jahr komme ich nicht wegen corona
bescherung für tauss wird uns nie
ja nächstes jahr komme ich ja wieder
aber nur zu den it services ich spreche
mit jürgen wie kann ich ihnen
weiterhelfen
ja haben sie mal versucht das gerät aus
und wieder einzuschalten hat nichts
gebracht verstehe ja probieren sie doch
mal den kanal der heute show auf youtube
zu abonnieren
genau und im zweifel ruhig auch mal den
gefällt mir -button klicken
genau ja ich bleibe in der leitung